una mattina avevo circa 13 anni
terno le fette e dovevo portare fuori il
cane prima di prima di andare a loro mi
sono vestito ho preso il guinzaglio sono
sceso nello stesso momento stava
tornando a mia madre da lavoro sono
fatto il turno di notte mi guarda e mi
fa gioco dove stai andando con in 15
anni in mano
guardo in mano che non si può portare il
cane
una volta che mi sono dimenticato
esattamente cliccare ciao ragazzi
benvenuti a un nuovo video qui sul mio
canale prima di iniziare in realtà
volevo sprecare due secondi per
ringraziarvi sia per la risposta che
avete dato al primo video di questa
rubrica e allo stesso tempo per i
versaggi che mi state mandando su
facebook ogni volta che manca una call
to action per avere insomma i vostri
pareri le vostre esperienze legate a
quelli che sono poi i temi della puntata
io direi di partire a questo punto è di
lanciare quello che sarà il tema di oggi
anno arrivando non avremmo dovuto rubare
questo film è più emozione che di quella
volta che avevo dimenticato come ci si
siede il mio rapporto con la mia memoria
è pessimo ma ho deciso in realtà di
portare del grande schermo di youtube
[Musica]
attraverso che a 20mila volte peggio di
me con me ci sta il mio fratello enrico
che mi sta guardando davanti un
termosifone dovrebbe andare il market
questo tempo posso dire che mi tocca
abbastanza da vicino perché nella mia
vita
così tra le varie cose hanno dimenticato
o dimenticato due computer
uno su un pullman e uno a un ristorante
e naturalmente sono stati rubati due
attimi dopo dimenticato anche se non
sbaglio due telefoni di cui uno sopra la
macchina e poi sono partito ho perso
purtroppo per i volte il portafogli ma
in realtà avevo dimenticato in un punto
l'ultima volta ho fatto una denuncia di
smarrimento avevo lasciato nel mio zaino
viene a questo punto di partire subito
all'arrembaggio e di ascoltare i vostri
messaggi che nessuno dimentica di
controllare cercate nella mia cantina
fosse entrata nel frigo senza lunghe
lami trovato quella volta in cui da
piccola sono andato al centro diventi
già ma perché mi sono dimenticata di
cambiarlo
come fai
i miei genitori non mi hanno detto
niente ciao tesoro inizia la ricreazione
con la mia alzari data insieme per i
dettagli in modo che tutta la ragazza è
ovviamente sarà a calcata attorno al
banco della mia più cara amica io monchi
ceno guardo un po in modo che c'era una
crostata alla nutella gira anche la
storia con una delicatezza chiedo ma
perché è portato sta cosa si gira lei
con tono gelido e mi fa oggi è il mio
compleanno a mio padre si dimentica ogni
anno di farmi gli auguri di compleanno
infatti quest'anno non glieli ho fatti
apposta non glieli ho fatti apposta
faceva 60 anni ma come grande che volevo
raccontare quella volta in commissione è
dimenticata di creare l'eccezione del
gabinetto
io poi avevo fatto a casa del mio
fidanzato ma ti giuro ero convintissimo
era verde tirato comunque esco dal bagno
tutto siamo qui gli ambiti insomma fare
e mia moglie è appena arrivò il mio
ragazzo entra in bagno insomma fare le
sue io lascio
[Musica]
aver lasciato il mio bisogno come dice
lui a gareggiare ha accolto da padrone
di casa io pensavo di essere veramente
uno con una memoria la pesce rosso ma io
mi rendo conto che veramente là fuori ci
sono persone orribili vero è vero
novembre il 24 esito berlino 26
anzi di che anno del web e del 1800 papa
1800 con contatti una volta in cui mia
madre che dimentica di chiudere il
teatrino ad abbandonare il mio cane
lavoratori
[Risate]
se lo dice così perché si è salvato
voglio dire no sì sì nel senso col
sorriso l'albergo in cui tutti noi
dimentichiamo di controllare ricchezza
perché teneva prima di fare la cacca
quanta verità io sai che volta che cosa
faccio lo faccio sto facendo
sto per dire una cosa che proprio cioè 1
st 2.0 di una volta utilizzato il rotolo
di cartone ero disperato mese ho fatto
uno scrub nella mia breve vita ti posso
dire che sto di aver avuto otto ragazze
ma mi ricordo solo di tre di loro
delle restanti 5 io non so non mi
ricordo che faccio anno e che non e
cognome anno
è una cosa un po preoccupante ci stavo
cantando giusto l'altro giorno ma meno
cosa lascia sconvolto danieli che se un
trapano da cantiere 120 ai vent'anni ha
avuto otto ragazze io a vent'anni e ho
iniziato a uscire fuori prima 0 cosmico
magari loro si sentono parte delle tre
capito io sono una di quelle tre che
sono dimenticata
mio fratello
una volta in cui mi sono dimenticata
anche il neonato sparito dormire
nell'asciugatrice e quindi è ovvio
tavole evidente che deve ancora fermata
subito dopo un paio di sono dimenticata
tanto non impianti e ciclo ci riesco a
capire che un azzardo ma è veramente
così tanto un azzardo perché un organo
dimenticato di farle gli auguri di
compleanno e anche l'anno dopo e quella
dopo ancora anziché tagliamo smerda
ringrazio te richiama merda la volta in
cui mi sono dimenticato la nonna e lini
era un pranzo di natale a casa di mio
zio circondati dai parenti e io non
vedevo l'ora di fuggire ottengo quindi
il permesso da mia madre di poter
scappare ha fatto però io e riporti a
casa la nonna e mia madre link a mia
nonna di aspettarmi sul ciglio della
strada in mezzo alla neve e io vado a
prendere la macchina per andare a casa
dopo dieci minuti mi arriva la
telefonata di mia madre che gli chiede e
mia nonna è arrivato a casa sana e salva
inizia quindi il momento di panico e
follia perché mi viene in mente che io
ho dimenticato la notte
da sola con ciglio di una strada in
mezzo alla neve richiesa una volta ios
non dovete a dirlo sono tornato un po la
discoteca mi sono dimenticata come si
apriva la porta e quindi ho dormito
tutte le rotolo perché non ricordavo
come per le chiavi ma questo serva tanti
sta e reader mente cioè ma come fai di
20 20 come si aprirà la portai ricordato
che cosa come si dorme su quella volta
in cui mi sono dimenticato il matrimonio
di un mio carissimo amico il quale fa un
po il seghetto alternativo quindi non è
sosta non ha sospeso gli do comparirà
nei fori di altri ma non esisti se non
stai su una settimana stremo solo le due
negate varie quindi l'ho rimosso è stato
figlio dal mare restate a metà
dell'autostrada di bocca del matrimonio
di matteo è che inchioda la macchina per
mogli scrive un messaggio di scusarmi
accampando scuse improbabili ci parla
sono malato o sempre scomparendo carbone
non posso venire dice non preoccupato
tanto il matrimonio è stato una
settimana fa quella volta in cui mi sono
diventa infatti lubrificante sul
comodino dei miei genitori e una volta
papà che a casa mi fanno carino questo
chiederà anche per le scelte nuovo dove
di cavalcare l'onda in quel caso è bene
che ha detto no molto l'uso mare
svariati finalmente alla fine di questo
video grazie arrivo per essere stato
commesso è stato veramente essenziale se
posso dire la mia
noi naturalmente ci vediamo con il
prossimo grazie per essere rimasti fino
a qui e niente vi auguro una buona
giornata una buona serata quello che
state facendo ciao di cisco prima stavo
lontano allora aspetta occhio della fai
cadere ci prova ma non so se funzionante
lo sai